well let me ask about not just the crazy
but the cruelty so in um
you've written one reporting as Steve
Jobs was told you that the big question
to ask was did he have to be so mean so
rough and cruel so drama addicted uh
what is this answer for Steve Jobs did
he have to be so cruel for jobs I asked
was at the end of my reporting because
that's what he asked said at the
beginning we're doing the launch of I
think
the iPad 2 it may have been Steve is
emaciated because you know he's been
sick and so I say to wise what's the
answer to your question and he said well
if I had been running Apple
I would have been nicer to everybody
everybody got stock options and we've
been like a family and then I I don't
know if you know Wise he's like a teddy
bear he paused he smiled and he said but
if I'd been running Apple
I don't think we would have done the
Macintosh or the iPhone so yeah you have
to
sometimes be rough and job said the same
thing that musk said to me which is he
said people like you love wearing velvet
gloves no I don't know that I've worn
velvet cloths often but you like people
to like you you like to sweet talk
things your sugarcoat things he says I'm
just a working class kid
and I don't have that luxury if
something sucks I got to tell people it
sucks or I got a team of B players well
musk is that way as well and it gets
back to what I said earlier which is
yeah
I probably would wear velvet gloves if I
could find them at my haberdasher uh and
I do try to sugarcoat things but when I
was running CNN it needed to be reshaped
it needed to be broken it needed to have
certain things blown up and I didn't do
it you know so
bad on me but it made me realize okay
I'll just write about the people who can
do it well that thing of saying I think
probably both of them but Elon certainly
saying things like that is the stupidest
thing I've ever heard
by the way I've heard Jeff Bezos say
that I've heard Bill Gates say that I've
heard Steve Jobs say it I've heard Steve
Jobs saying about a smoothie they were
making it a whole food or something I
mean people they use the word stupid
really often and you know who else used
it Arrow musk he kept banking Elon stand
in front of him and saying that's the
stupidest thing you're the stupidest
person you'll never amount to anything
um
I don't know you know as John McNeil the
president of Tesla said
do you have to be that way probably not
there are a lot of successful people who
are much kinder
but um
it's
sometimes necessary
to be much more brutal and honest
brutally honest I would say then people
like
or when Boss Of The Year trophies
well as you said this kind of idea did
also send a signal this idea Steve Jobs
of eight players it did send a signal to
everybody
it was a kind of encouragement to the
people that are all in right and that
happened to Twitter when we went to
Twitter headquarters the day before the
Takeover he was having Andrew and James
as two young cousins and other people
from the autopilot team going over lines
of code and musk himself sat there with
a laptop on the second floor of the
building looking at the lines of code
that had been written by Twitter
engineers and they decided they were
going to fire 85 percent of them because
they had to be all in and this notion of
psychological safety and mental days off
and
working remotely he said either and then
it came up uh actually one of his um
I think it was one of the cousins or
maybe Ross Nordeen came up with the idea
of let's not be so rough and just fire
all these people let's ask them do you
really want to be all in because this is
going to be hardcore it's going to be
intense you get to choose but by
midnight tonight we want you to check
the box I'm hardcore all in I'll be
there in person I'll work you know as
much or that's not for me I've got a
family I got work balanced
and you got different type of people
that way and different stages of their
life I was a little bit more hardcore
and all in when I was in my 20s than
when I was you know in my 50s and you
write about this it's a really nice idea
actually that there's two camps and you
find out I don't I wonder how true this
is it rings true you can just ask people
which Camp are you in are you the kind
of person that Prides themselves and
enjoy staying up to 2 A.M programming or
whatever or do you see the value of
quote-unquote you know about life work
life balance all this kind of stuff and
it's interesting I mean you like you you
could people probably divide themselves
in different stages in life and you can
just ask them and it makes sense for
certain companies in certain stages of
their development to be like uh we
always have teams it doesn't even have
to be a whole company and you're right
it goes back to what I was saying about
rule the first secret is sort of know
thyself obviously comes from Plato and
uh everything comes from Plato and
Socrates but
um
and
decide on this stage of my life am I do
I want to be a hackathon all in all
night and change the world or do I want
to bring wisdom and stability but also
have balance I think it's good to have
different companies with different
styles the problem was Twitter was at
almost one extreme with yoga studios and
mental health days off and uh enshrining
psychological safety as one of the
mantras that people should never feel
psychologically threatened and he a
member of the bitter laugh he Unleashed
when he kept hearing that word he said
no I like the words hardcore I like
intensity I like a intense sense of
urgency as our operating principle well
yeah they're people that way as well and
so know who you are and know what type
of Team you want to build versus
psychological safety and too many birds
everywhere oh yeah a lot of times musk
did things I go what the hell yeah and
among them was changing the name Twitter
and getting rid of the birds hey man
there's a lot invested in that brand
but when I watched him he thought okay
these sweet little chirpy birds tweeting
away in the name Twitter it's
not hardcore it's not intense and so for
better and for worse I think he's taking
Acts
into the hardcore realm with people who
post hardcore things with people with
hardcore views
it's not
a
polite playpen
for
the blue checked
anointed Elite
and I thought okay this is going to be
bad the whole thing's gonna fall apart
well it has had problems but the
hardcore intensity of it has also meant
that there's new things happening there
so it's very Elon Musk
to not like the sweetness of birds
chirping and tweeting and saying I want
something more hardcore